over in the horse race it's not looking
too good for President Biden he's now
losing to all three of the top
Republican contenders and there is
some okay we want all opinions here
that's but uh yeah and there's something
very bad politically looming for him
next week his
birthday uh he would like to avoid
this he
going to be 81 we've never had a
president who's 81 doesn't mean he can't
do it I'm just saying I like the guy but
I'm just saying if Joe Biden was a
balcony uh I wouldn't step out on him
for a
smoke the way
I
so and uh oh the Republicans they spent
the week threatening to beat each other
up I'm not making this up here's a newe
I didn't know this I had never heard
this name before this week apparently
he's a senator from Oklahoma Mark Wayne
Mullen
Mark sounds like a serial killer
actually a
Senator Senator Mark Wayne Mullen was
hearing
te testimony from the head of the
Teamsters Union and at one point he
stands up takes off his ring like let's
go bro this is the Senate Mitch
McConnell completely froze then he heard
about the all right you're way ahead of
me
but can can I can I recreate for you a
little bit the actual dialogue that went
on in the United States Senate between
this manand and a senator first guy says
you want to do it
now I'd love to do it now then stand
your butt up you stand your butt
up again this is a Senator Mark that's
his Mark Wayne Mullen his campaign
slogan Mark Wayne Mullen what the
are you looking
at and
then and then another Congressman
claimed former recently former uh house
Speaker head dude Kevin
McCarthy sucker punched him in the
kidney and Kevin McCarthy said hey if I
did that he'd be on the
ground
it's so embarrassing watching
these pencil necks trying to act all
hard yeah Kevin McCarthy
hard he's got a tear
tattoo for the time he killed Medicare
anyway